[Musique]
à la fin de la dernière glaciation des
migrants venant du moyen-orient
s'installe sur les terres qui entoure la
mer baltique et forme le peuple des
hypers vauréens ces gens vénèrent des
dieux géants aux pouvoirs surnaturels
les a's est l'un de ces dieux
l'inflexible destin à la tâche de juger
les auteurs de crimes
les suspects et sont soumis à l'épreuve
du feu et s'ils meurent ils sont
coupables
s'ils survivent ils sont innocents
[Musique]
les hyperboréens fonde hyper bord et
berceau de la civilisation arctique et
choisissent comme centre religieux la
péninsule de kola qu'ils horn de
pyramides et de temples cyclopéen
les hyperboréens vivent paisiblement
pendant des millénaires
quant à l'âge du bronze il se divise en
deux factions rivales et se font la
guerre totale c'est un massacre
il se termine quand les hyperboréens
vainqueur chasse les adversaires est
devenu lé seul maître de l'europe du
nord regroupe leurs clans formant le
peuple des proto germain
[Musique]
pour les hyperboréens vaincu c'est la
débandade
il s'enfuit à bord de leur bateau et
passant par la manche
devenu navigables il longe le continent
jusqu'à gibraltar et rentre dans la
méditerranée certains vont s'installer
en sardaigne formant le peuple des
sardanes et d'autres vont occuper
l'espace et j'ai un semblable à leur
lieu d'origine
formant le peuple des mycéniens
[Musique]
homi saignant succèdent les achéens et
puis les grecs qui hérite de la culture
hyperboréens haine et la transmettent
avec les épopées de dieu à la
physionomie nordique au maire raconte
que c'est dieu sont supérieurs aux
hommes mais qu'une entité encore plus
puissante règne sur le monde entier y
compris sur les dieux c'est le destin
le seigneur du futur ce seigneur se
déguise tantôt en femme et se fait
appeler chance
tantôt en homme et se fait appeler
hasard mais c'est toujours lui le destin
et que cela plaise ou non c'est lui qui
façonnent l'avenir des êtres humains
son apparition date il y à environ 60
milles ans quand un primate du genre
homo sort des limites du présent propre
au monde animal et se dote de la pensée
symbolique devenant l'être humain cette
évolution intellectuelle permet aux
humains de concevoir l'avenir
mais comme ils ne savent pas le
planifier
il croit que c'est un être supérieur qui
déroulent leur vie et l'appel destin
[Musique]
on raconte qu à chaque lever du soleil
le destin commence son travail en
éliminant tout d'abord les souhaits
impossible contrairement à ce que l'on
croit
les miracles ne sont pas de sa
compétence
[Musique]
le destin aime bien écouter les
motivations qui amènent les personnes a
désiré quelque chose ou quelqu'un mais
se met vite en colère quand il est
accusé à tort par les imprudents gare à
eux car alors il ajoute malheur au
malheur
[Musique]
dans le soleil se couche le destin
rédige ses décisions journalières dans
un livre uniquement consultable par les
dieux et les oracles et donne à ses
trois filles
la fileuse la réparatrice et
l'implacable l'ordre de faire et de
défaire la vie des êtres humains
[Musique]
pour leur part les êtres humains
craignent le destin ils le perçoivent
comme le régisseur des changements de la
vie et s'efforce de découvrir un système
pour connaître ses intentions
il y a trois mille cinq cents ans les
sages de la dynastie qin élabore en
chine
une méthode divinatoire l'oracle il
lance au sol des hausses de tortue et
selon leurs placements
ces eaux se donne une réponse négative
ou positive
il y a trois mille ans la notion de
destin donne lieu à diverses
interprétations toujours en chine
le héros civilisateur fut xi se base sur
les vibrations qui émane des êtres
vivants et prédit l'avenir par un oracle
numérique
inaugurant le système binaire appliqué
aujourd'hui par les ordinateurs
[Musique]
en inde les quatre veda révélé aux
hommes par le dieu brahma prétendre
échapper au destin est impossible et que
tout effort pour changer sa propre vie
est inutile
en israël le roi salomon affirme qu'il
n'y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil
même pas le destin puisque les
événements se succèdent dans un cycle
répétitif
[Musique]
dans l' empire perse cyrus le grand
moeurs et son fils aîné cambyse hérite
de la couronne
toutefois le fils cadet le prince bardia
profite d'une mission de cambyse en
egypte pour en usurpé le trône mais il
est capturé et emprisonné
mardi ya comprend alors que son destin
est de mourir jeune et que quand son
frère cambyse reviendra il le mettra à
mort mais un fait imprévisible renverse
la situation sur la route du retour
suite à une infection cambyse moeurs
unique héritier bach dia se réjouit de
son destin car au lieu d'être exécuté il
est couronné grand roi de lempire ps
mais le destin se moque de bach dia il
est aussitôt assassiné par une coalition
de militaires et c'est le général darius
qui prend le pouvoir en persie en grèce
dans les pièces de théâtre tragique tous
ceux qui tentent d'échapper à leur
destin finissent mal le fondateur du
stoïcisme et non soutient que le destin
se répètent sans que l'homme n'y puisse
rien changé
d'après le grand dramaturge d'athènes
euripide l'homme à la capacité
d'améliorer son propre destin
mais les passions le détourne de la
bonne conduite
le philosophe epicure lui ne croit ni au
destin ni aux dieux ni même à la bonne
conduite
il perçoit la création comme un ensemble
d'atomes qui se bougent dans le vide
selon leur besoin d'un semblement et qui
se croisent entre eux par hasard
produisant l'infinie diversité du monde
[Musique]
les souverains du monde par contre sont
très superstitieux
inquiet sur l'issue de leur bataille ils
se font une obligation de connaître les
mouvements du destin et lui est riche
alors un grand nombre de temples pour
qu'il révèle ses intentions aussi bill
aux voyants au prophète au chaman selon
les lieux en grèce c'est une vierge
sybille qui entrant donne des
prédictions sous une forme obscures à
rome
cicéron juge qu'un homme éveillé voit
mieux qu'un homme en transe et que si
les dieux veulent s'exprimer ils le font
clairement sans recourir aux mots
incompréhensibles
quant au destin cicéron soutient qu'il
est une conséquence du comportement
induits par la nécessité car une forte
nécessité amène l'homme à des erreurs
graves
alors qu'amd identique circonstances
dans une simple nécessité le même homme
s'en sort très bien
[Musique]
l'empereur marc aurèle est un décideur
nez ne te décourage pas si tu ne réussis
pas après un échec
ne te laisse pas troubler par l'avenir
mr recommence et aj mois empereur romain
je te dis que si tu sais affronter la
vie avec calme et discernement sans rien
attendre de personne et sans avoir peur
de rien tu seras heureux et personne pas
même le destin ne pourra l'en empêcher
à cette époque l'astronome grec ptolémée
affirme que le destin est influencé par
les astres remplaçant ainsi la volonté
divine par le calcul astrologique
mais d'après les chrétiens le destin
n'existe pas il est remplacé par le
libre arbitre ou rien n'est décidé d'
avance car chacun est responsable de ses
propres actes
[Musique]
dans l'islam au contraire le cours des
choses est décidé à l'avance mais si
dieu le veut ils permettent aux hommes
de modifier la fatalité
[Musique]
des cartes est un physicien français il
remarque que tel qu aux produits tels
effets mais avoue qu'il y a de
l'imprévisible dans l'antre monde
imprévisible qu'il appelle causalité
hasard le hasard est une suite de
circonstances non intentionnels qui
échappe à toute logique et à toute
connaissance
néanmoins l'homme tente d'escalader ce
mur infranchissable érigé entre le
présent et le futur
il cède alors avec le calcul des
probabilités
mais le hasard n'est pas mesurable
il n'a ni le sens de la logique humaine
ni celui de la justice
il peut aussi bien se courir la canaille
la plus misérable qu'entraver l'homme le
plus méritant du monde
[Musique]
ce qui est sagesse pour l'homme est
folie pour les dieux récite les veda
[Musique]
mais l'homme n'est pas une espèce
quelconque
il a survécu aux épreuves de la nature
allongeant même son espérance de vie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec l'avènement de
l'ordinateur aux circuits intégrés
utilisés par les militaires
le calcul des probabilités et mesurer
jusqu au 10 millionième chiffres ce qui
rend les données toujours plus précises
[Musique]
alors fort de sa technologie l'homme
repart à la conquête du destin de ces
imprévus et du mur érigé par le hasard
mais il trouve un autre mur celui de la
physique quantique qui définit le hasard
comme une force agissante au delà de la
physique classique le plaçant dans un
monde inconnu alors l'homme invente les
ordinateurs quantiques des millions de
fois plus performant que les ordinateurs
commun mais malgré ses efforts tout
change à chaque instant et personne ne
sait comment c'est peut-être parce que
l'homme n'est qu'un petit point
minuscule sur la planète terre
la terre aussi n'est qu'un petit point
dans notre système solaire qui est un
petit point dans la voie lactée notre
galaxie qui est un petit point
imperceptible dans l'immensité de
l'univers
et pourtant
malgré cet immense différence de
proportion l'homme se croient importants
il cultive l'idée que le dieu unique l'a
créé pour lui confier la terre et que ce
dieu l'observent du haut du ciel
s'occupant de ses besoins
dieu personne ne l'a jamais vu et il y a
plusieurs dieux uniques dans ce monde un
pour chaque nation
ces dieux sont bizarres d'abord il crée
les hommes et ensuite ils les laissent
s'entretuer en leur nom l'homme aussi
est bizarre il se dit croyant sans avoir
lu l'entièreté des textes sacrés texte
d'ailleurs obsolète car les originaux et
les auteurs sont inconnus
le croyant condamne les non croyants ou
châtiment de dieu et comme dieu
n'intervient jamais il se donne
arbitrairement la tâche de les châtier
lui même certaines religions oblige même
les prêtres à la chasteté ses hommes
sexuellement frustrée un bus alors de
jeunes crédules et finalement ruine la
réputation de leur église
l'homme pense que les femmes sont
inférieures les frappes les viols et les
ans h
mais les femmes abandonnent leur
féminité adopte une attitude masculine
et finalement elle supplante les hommes
dans les affaires de la famille du monde
l'homme pense qu'il n'y a que deux types
sexuelle le mâle et la femelle mais
ignorent qu'il en existe plus de 40 dans
la nature au sein des plantes des
animaux et donc de l'humanité cette
ignorance est due aux religions qui ont
institué la famille classique
considérant ceux qui ne sont ni homme ni
femme comme des créatures étranges
morphologiquement mal formés banni par
la société civile ces gens ce sont alors
refermés sur eux-mêmes et ne pouvant se
dédier à rien d'autre qu'un
l'accroissement de leur capacité
personnelle
ils en sont arrivés à exceller dans les
arts la mode le sport la science la
politique et même dans l'économie
finalement de par leur performance les
homosexuels ont supplanté les hommes
dans tous les domaines du monde
aujourd'hui le coming out devient
presque le sésame pour la réussite
l'homme blanc pense s'enrichir en
exploitant les terres des hommes noirs
finalement les exploitent et noir
envahissent les terres de l'homme blanc
menaçant sa culture
l'homme blanc
qui descend lui même de migrants noirs
et ignorent que loin de l'équateur la
peau devient clair en 2000 en devient
alors raciste l'homme sait que l'alcool
et le tabac tue mais il les vend au
public
il impose la limitation de vitesse sur
les routes mais il construit des
voitures qui la dépasse de beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant bien qu entraver par ses
propres contradictions
malgré les forces invisibles de la
nature et les embuscades du destin
l'homme ne s'avoue jamais vaincu
fermement décidée à forger l'avenir à
son avantage
il modifie le cours d eau
à bas les forêts massacre en masse les
animaux pour se nourrir rempli les
maires de déchets impérissable et
empoisonnent l'air avec sa technologie
n'y a pas besoin d'oracle pour
comprendre que la terre réagir à bientôt
avec ces anticorps est alors de l'espèce
humaine ne survivront que les
astronautes obliger à vivre quelque part
dans le cosmos
[Musique]
et si le roi salomon avait raison tout
ceci s'est déjà produit maintes fois
avec différentes sortes d'hommes
quant aux pirouettes du destin tout un
chacun sait comment s'y prend il ya ceux
qui choisissent la soumission fataliste
et ceux qui perçoivent l'adversité comme
un défi lancé à l'homme pour qu'il se
relève après la défaite car c'est en se
relevant que l'homme donne un sens à son
existence
[Musique]
mais c'est dur sans qu'on l'ait jamais
demandé l'avis nous invite à jouer à
colin maillard et en plus elle triche
face à ces pièges il vaut mieux perdre
le moins possible dans les revers et
acquérir le plus possible dans les
succès c'est la seule issue du jeu un
jeu qui dure trop peu car avant même
qu'on en comprenne les règles
la vie nous effleure et 120 pourtant
dans ce petit bout de temps la vie est
belle avec le ciel bleu les prêts les
fleurs et les parfums
enveloppé dans ses mystères la vie est
une aventure unique passionnant
dangereuse et pour cela grandiose
[Musique]